he's not leaving me alone and he always
said me I will kill you if you leave me
ranimu day could not have been more
clear to police about the danger to her
life she and her mother Carla Salim were
murdered by a man she'd repeatedly
reported for violence and threats
on the night of the murder Renee was in
a Shisha Lounge in Birmingham watching
her was her violent estranged husband
John bazderine
he's seen confronting her and gets angry
her name's mother fends him off he was
in breach of a court order put in place
to protect renim she calls 999 the first
of four calls that night that become
increasingly desperate
actually I'm having a trouble with my
ex-partner he's uh actually harming me
he's actually causing a risk for me and
he actually slept my mom as well and
then and it's really late and I'm
worried he might come to my prophecy and
hurt me again and finally please today
he should be arrested and he might just
get an eye for something and do
something to ask he did follow them to
their home and he did have a knife
the family heard the 999 calls for the
first time during the inquest Carla's
younger daughter was at home that night
aged just 14 at the time she saw the
attack I think it just
hurt even more now knowing that she
actually
cried for help and begged for them and
they did not come at all the death of my
sister and my niece could have been
prevented on the day of their murder and
previously though because ranita very
clear before that she was under threat
and perhaps her family
the coroner said this case raises
serious concerns about how West Midlands
police deal with cases of domestic
violence but this is just the latest
police force to be heavily criticized
for its handling of violence against
women
nine officers have since been
investigated for misconduct but none
have been dismissed
campaigners are increasingly concerned
this is definitely a national issue I
think there is an attitude amongst the
police force which is a a part of it
ingrained deep ingrained misogyny but
also the failure to just take domestic
abuse seriously assistant chief
Constable Andy Hill said on behalf of
West Midlands police I would like to
apologize to reneem and kiola's family
we should have done more the seriousness
and pattern of abuse should have been
recognized we are continually striving
to improve our response to domestic
abuse
but there will be women across the
country who recognize the fear this
mother and daughter felt and the failure
of police to help Becky Johnson's Sky
News Birmingham